اهلا بكم مشاهدينا في اخبار الساعه من
العربيه
امريكا والمانيا
بالدبابات وسويسرا توافقوا على تصدير
الاسلحه لكيف
تدريبات الاسرائيليه امريكيه تنطلق اليوم
في ضربه الهجوميه تستهدف مواقع نوويه
ايرانيه
وسط استعدادات امنيه تظاهره عراقيه قرب
البنك المركزي احتجاجا على ارتفاع سعر
الدولار
وزير الامن القومي الاسرائيليه تعاهد
باستمرار زيارته للمسجد الاقصى رغم الغضب
الفلسطيني
اهلا بكم مشاهدينا البدايه من تطورات
الحرب الاوكرانيه والدعم العسكريه
الامريكيه الغربي
ان اعلان البيت الابيض بشان ارسال
الدبابات ابرام سياتي اليوم الاربعاء
ان عمليه التدريب على ابرامز تستغرق شهورا
واوكرانيا لن تستلم تلك الدبابات على
الارجح قبل عام قبل ذلك قال المتحدث باسم
البنت تكون الجنرال باتريك رايدر في رد
على السؤال
او سؤال حول ارسال الدبابات او رمز
احتياجاته لمواجهه روسيا كما اشار الى ان
الدبابات امراض معقده وتحتاجه الى صيانه
دوريه وتدريب مكثف وصعب
تزويده العسكريه يعني اي عن تدريب
الاوكراني على هذه الاسلحه سنعمل على
تزويد اوكرانيا بكافه احتياجاتها
اللوجستيه انظمه الدبابات انظمه معقده
ويصعب صيانتها وعندما ناكد منح اوكرانيا
الدعم العسكريه اللازم سنعلن ذلك كما انه
ليس من المفيد ان نمنح اوكرانيا اسلحه
وانظمه لا تستطيع صيانتها سنعمل على احصاء
احتياجات اوكرانيا وتزوجها بما تحتاجه
ليكون لمساعدتنا اثر فعال في ميدان
المعركه نحن واضحون مستمرون باجراء نقاشات
مع اوكرانيا بشان متطلباتها الدفاعيه
قصيره وطويله الامل
في سياق ذاته قال مسؤول امريكيون لشبكه سي
ان ان الاداره الامريكيه تضع اللمسات
الاخيره على خطه ارسال نحو 30 دبابه من
طراز ابرامز على ان يصدر الاعلان في اقرب
وقت خلال الاسبوع الجاري واوضح المسؤولون
ان قرار التسليم اكيد في ما قد تستغرق
عمليه ارسال الدبابات وقتل
[موسيقى]
هذا واضح صحيفه الرياض السياسيه بين
الحلفاء الغربيين بشان تسليحي اوكرانيا
بدبابات
قتاليه متطوره
الصعبه وانما نقل هذه المركبات المدرعه
الثقيله والشاحنات القتاليه الاخرى الى
ساحه المعركه واوضحت نقلا عن مسؤول الامر
عن مسؤولين امريكي
قد يستغرقوا سنوات بينما تستعد روسيا لجنه
هجوم جديد متوقع في الربيع مضيفه ان
المخاوف تتمثل باستهداف روسي اثناء شحنها
الى الخطوط الاماميه في شرقي وجنوب
اوكرانيا
الروسيه
قالت المتحدث باسم البيت الابيض كارنج ان
الولايات المتحده تقدر بشده جهوده في
تقديم سعادتي العسكريه لاوكرانيا مؤكده ان
بلادها ستواصل العمل مع الحلفاء لمسانده
اوكرانيا للتاكد من انها قادره على خوض
هذه الحرب
اءنا وشركائنا في جهودهم لمساعده اوكرانيا
ولذا سنواصلوا تقديرنا وسنواصل شكرهم مره
اخرى وقد قلت ذلك في سؤالك لي انه قرار
سيادي الامر متروك لكل دوله لتقرر كيف
ستقوم بدورها في مساعده اوكرانيا وفي
القتال ضد العدوان الروسي لكن كما تعلمين
هؤلاء هم حلفاءنا هؤلاء هم شركائنا
وسنواصل العمل معهم عن كذب للتاكد من ان
الاوكرانيين قادرين على خوض هذه الحرب
الوحشيه
انتقل الجدل والانتقادات الغربيه لبرلين
حول تزويد اوكرانيا بدبابات اليوبار الى
جدار سياسيه في الداخل الالماني فبعد
اسابيع من ترديد المانيا
الى اوكرانيا والذي انتهى باعلان موافقه
مستشارك على تجويدها بدبابات عاده صراع
مجددا لكن من الداخل الالماني حيث وصف
رئيس المشارك في حزب البديل من اجل
المانيا
على الجيش الالماني
سيترق جيشه ويخاطر بالتوارق في الصراع وان
القرار غير مسؤول وخطير ويهدد المانيا
مباشره الى الصراع معتبرا ان عمليه السطو
ستستمر بتزويده بالدبابات الموجوده في
الخدمه مع الجيش الالماني على حد قومها
مين نقدر لنا تنضم الينا بواسطه العربيه
رغده بحمام اهلا بك رغده ما عاد مدى عمق
هذه الخلافات او حاله الجداء المثاره في
الداخل الالماني بسبب قبول الحكومه
الالمانيه تسليم هذه الدبابات الى قانيه
في البرلمان الحزبين الرئيسيين في الحكومه
اللذين كان يدفعان المستشار الالماني اللي
اتخاذ قرار ارسال الدبابات رحبا بهذه
الخطوه حزب المعارضه الاكبر حزب
الديمقراطي المسيحي الذي تنتمي اليه
المستشاره السابقه انجيلا ميركل ايضا ارحب
بهذه الخطوه وقال انها حتى جاءت متاخره
الاعتراض الوحيد الذي ياتي ياتي من
الحزبين الاصارين همم في البرلمان الحزب
اليمين المتطرف البديل الالمانيه التي
تتحدث عنه يعني في الخبر قبل القليل ومن
الحزب يعني اليسار المتطرف همم هذا
الحزبان ومع اصلا حزبان لروسيا منذ
البدايه يعرضون اي نوع من المساعده تقدمها
الحكومه الالمانيه لروسيا حزب البديل
لالمانيا اليمين المتطرف همم يعني هو
معروف بعلاقته المقربه من روسيا وحزب
اليسار المتطرف ايضا لاسباب تاريخيه لانه
هو يعني قيمه او على اسس همم يعني بقايا
الاتحاد الحزب الشيوعي في المانيا عندما
كان الاتحاد السوفيتي اا يعني في المانيا
الشرقيه لذلك هذان الحزبان رغم انهما
بالفعل يعارضان بشده هذا القرار ولكن
اصواتهما ليست كثيره في الويندوز تاج همم
وايضا يعني كان هناك استطلاع للراي
الاسبوع الماضي همم مع السكان يسال ما اذا
كانوا يؤيدون قرار ارسال الدبابات وكان
يعني الاكثريه تؤيد ارسال هذه الدبابات
لذلك همم ربما ايضا من هنا كانت تردد
شولتي لانه اراد ان يتاكد من انه هناك
اجماع داخل المانيا على ارسال هذه
الدبابات قبل ان يتخذ هذه الخطوه المهمه
جدا همم والتي من المفترض ان يعلنها رسميا
اليوم في همم يعني في كلمه امام البنت
بهذا القدر شكرا لك من برلين كنت معنا
ممارسه العربيه رغده باهنى تحيه رغده
الى ردود الفعل الروسي حيث دعى نائب رئيس
مجلس الامن الروسي ديميترميد فيدي فقد
الولايات المتحده والمانيا لوقف دقات
عقارب الساعه النوويه وذكرت نشرته علماء
الذره ان عقارب الساعه يوم القيامه التي
تشير الى خطر حدوث كارثه عالميه قد وصلت
الى رقم قياسيا قريب بمنتصف الليل النووي
قبل 90 ثانيه من ذلك وقال لي وكاله سبور
الروسيه ردا على سؤال ما العمل لاعاده هذه
الساعه الى الوراء انه يجب على صانعي
الساعات ويعني ان يوقف هذا قات الساعه
الذريه لفتره بها الوقت مضيفا للقيام بذلك
عليهما ان يفهمها ان سهماهم الاوكراني
صديق منذ فتاه طويله حسب قولها
هذا الخبر العاجل خارجي الروسيه تقول ان
المناقشات مع الغرب بشان الخطوط الحمر شيء
من الماضي
قال سفير روسيا لدى الولايات المتحده انا
تولي انتنوف ان عمليه تسليم دبابات قتاليه
محتمله من قبل واشنطن الاوكرانيا ستكون
استفزادا صارخا اخر لروسيا وقال انتونو في
تصريحات نشرت على تطبيق تيليجرام ان
واشنطن وبكل وضوح تحاول عن قصد الحاقه
هزيمه الاستراتيجيه
انه اذا قررت الولايات المتحده تزويد اخرى
بالدبابات فان تغير مثل هذه الخطوه بالحجج
حول الاسلحه الدفاعيه لن ينجح بالتاكيد
مشاهدينا من موافق العربيه
لكي تتضح الصوره اكثر كاتيا كيف تلقفت
موسكو هذا النبا حول موافقه اوكرانيا او
موافقه عفوا المانيا ارسال هذه الدبابات
الى اوكرانيا
طيب يبدو انك تسمعني سعودي اليك كانتي مره
اخرى في سياق هذه النشره
مشاه
البرلمان باللجنه في البرلمان السويسي
لصالح مقترح يسمحوا بطلب تعديل قوانين
البلاد بهدف ايتاحه تصدير اسلحه سويسريه
الى اوكرانيا عبر دول اخرى وتضمن الاقتراح
ماده تسمح بالغاء تعاهدات عالمي اعاده
التصدير التي يجب على الدول التي تشتري
اسلحه السويسريه التوقيع عليها في بعض
الحالات الخاصه وابقى الاقتراح الباب
مفتوحا امام الحكومه السويسريه لوقف اعاده
تصدير الاسلحه في الحالات التي يشكل فيها
ذلك مخاطر كبيره على سياسه الخارجيه
السويسريه
والى حمله الاقالات والاستقالات الواسعه
في اوكرانيا المعلن اخيرا جاءتك اولي
واكبر فضيحه بهذا الحجم منذ بدا الحرب في
اوكرانيا وذلك بعد اعلان الحكومه
الاوكرانيه لقاله نحو 12 مسؤولا والاقاله
نحو 12 مسؤولا على خلفيه قضيه فساد تتعلق
بعمليات شراء امدادات للجيش باسعار مبالغ
فيها الرئيس الاوكرانيسكي اعتبر ان هذه
الاقالات هي عمليه تطهير ضروريه متعهدا
باتخاد اجراءات اضافيه مؤكدا ان عمليه امر
منصف وضروريه للدفاع عن اوكرانيا فضلا عن
انها تدعم التقارب مع المؤسسات الاوروبيه
اما الولايات المتحده فقد رحبت بدورها
بالاقالات معلنه انه لم يتم اي اموال
امريكيه قدمت لمساعده اوكرانيا
كم اعتبر متحدث باسم الخارجي الامريكيه
نيترو برايس ان الشعب الاوكرانيه كان
واضحا جدا بشان رغبته في الحكم النزيه
والشفافيه من جهه ثانيه قال نائب وزير
الدفاع الاوكراني في الجيش
وهو احد الذين استقال على خلفيه هذه
القضيه قال ان الفضيحه هجوم مصطنع يستند
الى حجج واحد
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
نقعد مره اخرى
دبابات الالمانيه الى اوكرانيا
بهذه الدبابات من قبل المانيا على
العلاقات مع المانيا طبعا في المستقبل
اليوم سفير روسيا في واشنطن تحدث ايضا عن
احتمال تزويد واشنطن همم اوكرانيا
في اوكرانيا عند وصولها الى هناك من قبل
القوات الروسيه همم
ان هذه العمليه العمليه تزويد اوكرانيا
بالسلاحيه بمثابه تصعيد العمليه العسكريه
الروسيه وهي تؤثر اولا تمنع وجود محادثات
بين جانب الروسي والاوكراني فقط تزيد من
عدد ضحايا المدنيين على الاراضي
الاوكرانيه احمد
طيب اكاتيا بيحسب ما يراه مراقبون وايضا
المحللون العسكريون في روسيا ما هي الخطوه
المقبله
للمقابل عفوا لروسيا للرد على هذه الخطوه
التسليح النوعي الكبير لاوكرانيا
العسكريين ان يكون هناك طبعا تصعيد من
الجانب الروسي هذا لم تخفيه موسكو طبعا
اولا كان الكلام قال انه سيتم حرق جميع
الدبابات التي ستصل الى اوكرانيا
نائب رئيس مجلس الامن الروسي
عن امكانيه حدوث مواجهه مباشره بين روسيا
وحلف النت في حال نستمر
طبعا لم يستبعد احتمال وقوع حرب نوويه بين
القوه العظمى في العالم
تحياتي كثيره
نشاطره مستمره مشاهدينا وفيها بعد الفاصل
تدريبات الامريكيه اسرائيليه لمحاكاه قصف
اهداف نوويه ايرانيه
خطوات نمضيها بكل ثقه
فصيله بنا الى اهدافنا
سواء كنا لاعبين او محللين او مشجعين
بطمحوا لعالم يتخطى الذي نعرفه عالم اكثر
شفافيه متوجا بالمجد تعيش فيه اجمل
اللحظاتنا قد ننجح وقد نتعب
لكننا لا نستسلم
فيلم اسرع واقوى وافضل
فنحن واثقون من انفسنا من المضي قدما
الكره السعوديه في المرمى مع بتالي الجوز
من الثلاثاء الى الخميس منتصف الليل على
شاشه العربيه
منذ اكتشافه وحتى يومنا هذا
نعتمد على النفقه ومشتقاته في سبل الحياه
توليد الطاقه قطاع النقل والمواصلات
الوقود واكثر من 300,000 منتج اخر ليلعب
دورا مهما في الاقتصاد العالمي
لكن في ظل التطورات التي يشهدها العالم
والبحث المستمر عن مصادر متجدده للطاقه
كيف سيكون المشهد
اتعرف على كل التطورات واخر المستجدات
المؤثره في هذا القطاع الحيوي من صناع
القرار وخبراء العالم مستقبل الطاقه مع
ناصر الطيبي الخميس السادسه والنصف على
شاشه العربيه
اهلا بكم مشاهدينا من جديد افاد مراسل
العربيه بان تدريب المشتركا بين القوات
الجويه الاسرائيليه والقياده المركزيه
الامريكيه سيقصف اهداف تحاكي مواقعه نوويه
ايرانيه اليوم الاربعاء وحسب تقرير
للتلفزيون الاسرائيلي فانه امريكيه ستلقي
مئه متفجرات على اهداف في صحراء النقب
بجنوب اسرائيل وكانت القياده المركزيه
الامريكيه نشرت بيان حول مشاركه اكثر من
140 طائره من بينها
52 استراتيجيه وطائره اف 35
ورجمات صواريخ في التمرين المشترك الذي
سيصل لذروته اليوم
[موسيقى]
من القدس مشاهدينا مراسل العربيه زياد
حلبي اهلا بك يا زياد اذا نتحدث عن
تدريبات المشتركه هي الاكبر بين تل ابيب
واشنطن ما هي ابرز ملامح هذا اليوم زياد
وهي الاكثر ضجيجا بدون ان شك ان المناورات
تصل ذروتها اليوم من خلال محاكاه استهداف
منشاه نوويه ايرانيه تحت الارض في صحراء
النقب حيث تسقط القذفات والمقاتلات
من
القذائف الخارقه للتحصينات وليس قصف عاديه
همم عمليا وتغادر في خلال الثلاثه الى
اربعه دقائق سماء المكان في محاكاه لامكان
ان تستهدف اسرائيل المنشات وان تغادر على
عجل سماء ايران ايه في حينه همم بحسب
مراقبين بالفعل يبدو بان الامريكيين من
يريدون الضجيج لهذه المناورات وان تكون
علانيه ومعروفه الاهداف في اطار محاوله
توجيه رساله راجعه لايران اساسا ما افادها
بان هناك تحضيرات لضربات للمنشات النوويه
فيما اذا قررت ايران على الانطلاق
تجاه
امتلاك السلاح النووي
الامر الذي يقلق همم اسرائيل والغرب حاليا
هو قضيه امكان الانتقال في خلال ثلاثه
اسابيع قررت ايران من التقسيط بنسبه 60%
الى 90% التي تحتاجها لتصنيع القنبله
النوويه وتملك مواد اشتري انشطاريه تكفي
لاربع قنابل حاليا الى متى ستستمر هذه
التدريبات زياده هل اليوم هو اليوم الاخير
عمليا ستستمر يوما همم اخر همم هذه
المناورات بين الجانبين طبعا هي سبق وان
ايه ايه تدرب الجانبان ايضا على الاستهداف
المنشات مرتين قبل هذه المره ولكن عمليه
في اسرائيل والملاحظ ان الامريكيين هم من
يفرج عن المواد الفيلميه لهذه المناورات
وليس الجيش الاسرائيلي حاليا همم ربما همم
كما قلنا في اطار الاشاره الى الى رساله
راضيه رغم ان التقديرات في اسرائيل بان
واشنطن لن تشارك في ضرب المنشات النوويه
في ايران ولا تؤيد ضربه اسرائيليه مستقله
كذلك الامر اسرائيل تتدرب على هذه الضربه
لتنفيدها بشكل مستقل وحاليا وابقى اقرار
المؤسسه الامنيه فيها ما زالت غير جاهزه
لكنها تملك من سنه الى سنه ونصف عمليا
مثلا تركيب الرؤوس النوويه هو قد يكون
الفيصل متاب
كان الحكومه الاسرائيليه راضيه بمستوى
التنسيق والتعاون بينه والولايات المتحده
على خلفيه الخطا القادمه الايراني ام انها
تطالب بالمزيد من الجهود من الولايات
المتحده
ليس هناك مشكله في التنسيق الامني
والمناورات المشتركه بين اسرائيل
والولايات المتحده لكن هناك مشكله ثقه
كبيره ما بين بنيامين نتنياهو بايدن مع
والاداره الديمقراطيه فقط راينا نتنياهم
مؤخرا يتحدث انه في حال قرر شن هجوم مستقل
على المنشات النوويه الايرانيه لن يخبر
مسبقا للامريكيين لانه يخشى من ان اداره
ستسرب ذلك للاعلام الامريكي في في محاوله
لمنع ذلك هذا هو مستوى انعدام الثقه حاليا
هناك محاوله لترميم ذلك راينا همم
القومي الامريكي يصل اسرائيل ويطلب ايضا
استمرار التنسيق هذا التنسيق وربما من
خلال المباراه ايضا ولكن طلب بشكل واضح
عدم مفاجاه اسرائيل لواشنطن فيما يتصل
بايران من القدس
المحل مدير السابق لوكاله المخابرات
المركزيه ووزير الخارجيه الامريكيه السابق
مايو في كتابه الجديد لا تعطي شبرا الى ان
وكاله المخابرات المركزيه ساعدت عملاء
الموساد على الفراري من ايران في فبراير
2018 بعد ان نجحوا في سرقه ارشيف ايران
النووي بحسب تقرير لصحيفه الاسرائيليه
وقالت الصحيفه انه على الرغم من ان لم
يذكر اسم العمليه او الفتره الزمنيه الا
انه وصفها بانها واحد من اهم العمليات
السريه التي تم اجرائها على الاطلاق
في العراق كشفت قياده عمليات بغداد عن خطه
المتكامله لتامين الحمايه المتظاهرين خلال
الاحتجاجات المرتقبه اليوم قرب البنك
المركزي على ارتفاع سعر صرف الدولار مقابل
الدينار وقال قائد عمليات بغداد الفريق
الركن احمد سليم ان قياده وزعت القطاعات
الامنيه المتمثله بوحدات لحفظ القانون وهي
وحدات متخصصه من وزاره الداخليه لتوفير
الحمايه المتظاهرين مؤكدا انه لها قطع لاي
طريق في بغداد في حال الضروره
مين بغداد مشاهدينا ينضم الينا مراسل
العربيه سامي الكبيسي اهلا بك سامر متى
ستنطلق التظاهرات من يقف خلفه ومن سيشارك
فيها ايضا
في البدايه صباح الخير احمد فعلا مازلنا
نترقب انطلاق هذه التظاهرات التي دعا
اليها ناشطون من حركه تشرين واناشطونه
مدنيون تحديدا من محافظه النجف محافظه
بابل بالاضافه الى ما موجود هنا في
العاصمه بغداد بدا التجمع الان تحديدا في
الجانب الاخر احمد تستطيع ان ترى همم من
خلفي البنك المركزي والتعزيزات الامنيه
التي وصلت منذ ساعات الصباح الاولى الى
هنا لحمايه المتظاهرين اولا وحمايه
الممتلكات العامه هناك استغفار امني من
قبل همم يعني مجموعه من القطاعات الامنيه
متمثله بقوات حفظ القانون وبعض هو الامن
الداخلي اضافه الى كل ذلك مجموعه من
المتظاهرين كانوا قد وصلوا قبل نصف ساعه
تقريبا من الان لكن على جانب الاخر ننتظر
وصول التظاهرات تحديدا الى مبنى البنك
المركزي حيث يعني همم من المنتظر ان تبدا
التظاهره هنا ربما بعد من الان هناك
مجموعه من المتظاهرين من المحافظات الاخرى
ينتظر وصولهم الى هنا من محافظه بابل
ومحافظه النجف وحتى بعض محافظات الجنوب
لكن الى الان لا يوجد وقت محدد لهذه
التظاهرات احمد فيما يخص حتى الشعارات
ربما الشعار الابرز هو همم خفض سعر صرف
الدولار مقابل الدينار خاصه انه سجل يعني
ارقام قياسيه همم وصلت الى اكثر من 20,000
دينار اي ما يعادل تقريبا 16 الى 15 دولار
زياده عن السعر الذي يبيعه البنك المركزي
تسبب طبعا في حاله من الركود التجاري
بالاضافه الى زياده في اسعار السلع طيب من
الحكومه العراقيه اتخذت خطوات المهمه في
الايام الماضيه همم ضد مضاربين في اسعار
العمله مهربينه همم ولبعض ضد بعض ايضا
المسؤولين في البنك المركزي هل تلقى هذه
الخطوات والاجراءات الترحيبه من الشارع
احمد فعلا الحكومه العراقيه برئيس الوزراء
محمد شياع السوداني اتخذت مجموعه من
الاجراءات منها اقتصاديه منها امنيه منها
حتى على مستوى اجراءات من البنك المركزي
الى البنوك الاهليه وشركات الصيرفه لكن
جميع هذه الاجراءات لم تفلح حتى الساعه
بالسيطره على سعر صرف الدولار مقابل
الدينار ربما ستكون هناك اجراءات جديده
بحسب محافظ البنك المركزي بعض المصادر همم
تحدثت عن محافظ البنك المركزي الجديد علي
العلاق يحاول ببعض الاجراءات للسيطره على
سعر صرف الدولار مقابل الدينار ننتظر هذه
الاجراءات والتطبيقها على الشارع
الكبيسي من بغداد العربيه شكرا لك يا سامر
نبقى في العراق حيث قال رئيس الوزراء
العراقي محمد شيع السوداني ان ميلاده
بحاجه دائمه الى مراجعه العلاقه مع
التحالف الدولي في ظل تطور القدرات
القتاليه لقواتها المسلحه واعرب في مقالي
لصحيفه اللوموند الفرنسيه عن ركبه بلاده
في ترسيخ التعاون العسكري والامني مع
الجانب الفرنسي وتعزيز التعاون المشترك
لرفع قدرات الامنيه والقتاليه للقوات
العراقيه وهكذا السوداني على ان حكومه
بغداد ستسعى لتطويل العلاقات الاقليميه
والدوليه على اسس التعاون والتوازني
والاتحاد
ابدا مجموعه من اعضاء مجلس الشيوخ
الامريكي في تصريحات العربيه السياحه من
طريقه التعامل النظام الايراني
المتواصله في البلاد حيث طالبه كل من جون
كورنينو مايك براون الى جانب السيناتور
هام بتقديم مزيد من الدعم للشعب الايراني
مثل كوريا الشماليه وروسيا وعدد قليل من
الاماكن الاخرى التي يبدو انها تضغط على
اي قضيه تتعلق بحقوق الانسان
واعتقد انه سيكون كمساءله عن ذلك لقد سائم
الشعب الايراني من النظام يدير اقتصاده
ويسلبه بشكل متزايد الكثير من الحقوق طوال
الوقت
لا اعتقد اننا نفعل ما يكفي لتسويه الامور
مع ايران ولن نتحمل ما يفعلون لذلك اعتقد
انه من المهم ان نبقي اعيننا على ما يجري
ونمنع خروج الامر عن السيطره هناك اشخاص
يقاومون ونحاول ابعاد الاذى عنهم
الشعب الايراني بكل طريقه ممكنه ومحاسبته
النظام الايراني الذي قام بقتل بعض الناس
وهو يعتبر اكبر دوله راعيه للارهاب يجب
ازالته اي شك بشان ايران النظام الايراني
تعامل مع الاحتجاجات بطريقه وحشيه من
الصعب مشاهدتها
الشعبيه في ايران بشكل تدريجي الاساليب
القمريه التي يستخدمها النظام الايراني
وافق تقرير لشبكه سي ان ان الامريكيه
نتابع
اساليب قمعيه واعدامات متتاليه كانت هي
السلاح الابرز للنظام الايراني لمواجهه
الغضب الشعبي فبعد مرور اربعه اشهر من
الاحتجاجات وتنام الاستياء الشعبي بشكل
غير مسبوق تلا شازخم التظاهرات لكن الغضب
في اعلى مستوياته الاحكام القاسيه التي
كانت موجهه ضد المنشقين والاقليات العرقيه
والنساء على وجه التحديد
جعلت بقيه المتظاهرين الايرانيين يخشون من
مواجهه نفس المصير سلسله الاعدامات لم تكن
السبب الوحيد في تلاش هذه الاحتجاجات
الشعبيه فهناك عوامل اخرى مثل قتل
المتظاهرين بالرصاص والاعتقالات الجماعيه
والاعتداء الجسدي والعنف الجنسي
كلها عوامل اساسيه كان لها دور في انخفاض
المعارضه من الشارع الايراني من جهه
وازدياد الاستياء الشعبي العام من جهه
اخرى
وتحديدا في المناطق الحدوديه التي تهيمن
عليها الاقليات والتي تحملت العب الاكبر
من قمع النظام
وكما يرى مراقبون فان معظم الاشخاص الذين
تزيد اعمارهم عن 25 عاما ابتعدوا عن
المظاهرات
بالاضافه الى الجيل الاكبر سنا منهم
والذين ضلوا الى حد كبير بعيدا عن الشوارع
التي تعمها الاحتجاجات
وهو الامر الذي حرم الحركه الاحتجاجيه
الزخم اللازمه لاسقاط النظام الايراني
بان تعود هذه الانتفاضه مجددا ضد النظام
الايراني بسبب عدم قدرته على معالجه
المشاكل الاقتصاديه المتفاقمه بسبب
العقوبات الدوليه المفروضه عليها
سلطان العيبان العربيه
قال وزير الامن القومي الاسرائيلي اثمار
اليوم الاربعاء انه سيستمر في زياره
المسجد الاقصى ونقلت هيئه البث الاسرائيلي
عن بني خفير قوله في حديث اذاعي ان
اسرائيل دوله مستقله وغير تابعه لاي دوله
اخرى واضافت الهيئه ان تصريحات بنغفير
جاءت بعد يومين من تعهد رئيس الوزراء
الاسرائيلي من يمن نتنياهو للملك عبد الله
الاردني الملك عبد الله الثاني بالحفاظ
على الوضع القائم في الاماكن المقدسه
نستطيع مستمره مشاهدينا وفيها بعض الفاصل
جماعه افغانيه معارضه تهاجم قاعدتين لحركه
الطالبان وتاثيره ثلاثه عشره
البعد يقول بانو الناس
تهو اليوم البعد عن وقعها وحياته والاتجاه
نحو الخيال والاحلام
كانكم انتم تعيشون في ابراج مختلفه
الناس توجيه الاخرين
كلمه تعمل فيك يا اخي لو اجتمع المصلحون
على انسان لا يريد ان يتحرك او يتغير
والله لن يتغير المرحله الملكيه يا صديقي
ليس الدعوه الى القعود والعزال عن الحياه
في علم الاخلاق يقول دائما الفضيله بين
فضيلهتين متى يمكن يوصل الانسان للمرحله
الملكيه المساله لها علاقه بعمره لا اثبت
الكمال لكن في البعض احيانا نفسه قصير
سؤال مباشر مع خالد مدخلي الجمعه الخامسه
والنصف على شاشه العربيه
القوات الروسيه هنا اطلقت النار بشكل
عشوائي على المنازل
هذه المدينه التي تم حصارها لاكثر من
الشهره
هنا في هذه الحفره سقطت القذيفه
هذا هو مسرح وسينما المدينه حصريا لقناتي
العربيه والحدث نفسه ما حدث في هذه القريه
واثار القتال
امريكا والمانيا تتجهان لتزويد اوكرانيا
بالدبابات وسويسرا توافق على تصدير
الاسلحه لكيف
تدريبات الاسرائيليه امريكيه تنطلق اليوم
تحاكي ضربه الهجوميه تستهدف مواقع نوويه
ايرانيه
وسط استعدادات امنيه تظاهره عراقيه قرب
البنك المركزي احتجاجا على ارتفاع سعر
الدولار
وزير الامن القومي الاسرائيلي يتعهد
باستمرار زيارته للمسجد الاقصى رغم الغضب
الفلسطيني
اهلا بكم مشاهدينا من جديد اعلن جبهه
المقاومه الافغانيه المعارضه ان عناصرها
هاجمت قاعدتين بحركه الطالبان في ولايه
نورستان شرق البلاد واضرب نار في قاعدتين
تابعتين للحركات كما ذكرناه واثره 13 شخصا
من عناصر الحركه في ما لم يصدر اي رد
رسميا من طالبان واوضح المتحدث باسم
الجبهه صبغه الله احمد في تغريده عبر حساب
تويتر
في هذا الهجوم ولم تنشر الجبهه الافغانيه
اي صور او مقاطع فيديو تتعلق بالحادثه
لكننا الناشطين افغان تداول مقطع فيديو
قالوا انه هجوم الذي استهدف قوات حركه
طالبان في ولايه نورستان
هذا وتستمر الامم المتحده في بدل مجهودات
لاقناع حكومه طالبان بالعدول عن قراراتها
المجحفه في حق النساء مجهودات تزاملت مع
احتجاجات من قبل الافغانيات في مخصصه
اليونسكو اليوم العالميه للتعليم هذا
العام لافغانستان
من قرار طالبان منعهن من التعليم انتشرت
عبر وسائل التواصل الاجتماعي
اليوم هو اليوم الدولي للتعليم والذي تم
تخصيصه لافغانستان ولكن مع الاسف اين
ابواب الجامعات والمدارس مغلقه امام
الفتيات الافغانيات لا لجامعه طالبان لا
لمدارس طالبان لا لحكومه طالبان
نت مع اليوم العالمي للتعليم الذي خصصته
اليونسكو هذا العام لدعم الافغانيات في
حقهن بالتعليم حيث طلب الامين العام للامم
المتحده الحركه بالعدول عن قراراتها التي
منعت اكثر من مليون فتاه من الالتحاق
بالمدارس واكثر من مئه الف طالبه من
ارتياد الجامعه ومنع مئات الالاف منهن من
العمل
امر القامه العديد من الافغانيات بالتظاهر
ضده في عده مناسبات
وفي مواجهه تعلم قيادات طالبان في قندهار
ضاعفه الامم المتحده جهودها لاقناع الحركه
بالتراجع عن قراراتها عبر وفود الامميه
وانسانيه حيث جمدت العديد من المنظمات
الاغاثيه نشاطها في افغانستان بعد قرار
الحركه منع الافغانيه من العمل في هذه
المنظمات
الامر الذي يعرض الملايين من الافغاني
لخطر المجاعه
انس نماسي العربيه
[موسيقى]
نقف افغانستان حيث تسبب الطقس البارد
وحوادث الطبيعيه مختلفه في مقتل العشرات
حاليا
ابرد الايام والليالي حيث تصل درجه
الحراره الى 20 درجه تحت الصفر
يعيش في هذا المنزل المتواضع بضواحي
العاصمه كابول هذا البيت المتهالك لا يقيه
واسرته برد الشتاء القارس ويعرض اطفاله
للاصابه بامراض عديده حيث يرقد حاليا احد
اطفاله بالمستشفى بسبب البروده الشديده
مشكلاته
فلا نستطيع تامين وسائل التدفئه من الحطب
والمدفئه مرض اطفالي واذهب بهم يوميا الى
المشافي
وبحسب وزاره مكافحه الكوارث الطبيعيه
التابعه لحكومه طالبان فان حوالي اربعه
اشخاص لقوا حذفهم جراء البردي والفيضانات
والتسمم بالغاز وان 50 منزلا دمرت بالكامل
كما هلك سبعون الف راس من الماء
والامطار ايضا في سد الطريق بين مقاطعه
كابول وكذلك الطرق لسبعه من المحافظات في
بمركز المقاطعه
بالتزامني مع موجات البرد الشديد في
العديد من المقاطعه تفيد مؤسسات تقدم
خدمات صحيه عن زياده في امراض الجهاز
التنفسي وخاصه الالتهاب الرئوي والسعال
والاذن والحنجره بين الاطفال والبالغين
يسقط هؤلاء الضحايا نتيجه موجات البرد في
وقت يحذر مكتب تنسيق المساعدات الانسانيه
التابعه للامم المتحده اوتشا من زياده غير
مسبوقه في الطقس البارد وان البروده ستصل
الى 35 درجه تحت الصفر في اجزاء مختلفه من
افغانستان نهايه هذا الاسبوع عبد القادر
العربيه كابول
فتح في محافظه مارب معرض مفتوح للصور
الفوتوغرافيه حمل عنوان شتاء صنعاء وعكسه
الصور التي علقت على جدار احد الشوارع
الرئيسيه في مارب الوضع الانسانيه
والحقوقيه في العاصمه الخاضعه لسيطره
ميليشيات الحوثيه وانتهاكاتها في حق اليمن
صنعاء خلال ثمانيه سنوات من سيطره
الميليشيات الحوثيه عليها
اليمنيون من قبل في جداريه مارب المفتوحه
صور تمثل شهادات على تلك الجرائم وكشفا
لما يحصل في صنعاء
الاطفال طائره التعليم
المناهج طالت الاموال العامه ونهب الاموال
انتهاكات قالت الصحافه والصحافيين
اليمنيه لم تكتفي الميليشيات الحوثيه
باهانتها في طوابير البحث عن الماء والغاز
بل جدتها في تشكيلات مسلحه تابعه لها
اطلقت عليها الزينبيات
واسندت اليهن مهام امنيه واستخباراتيه
واقتحام المنازل واعتقالا النساء وتعذيبهم
شواهد لفتت انظار زوار معرض الصور
المفتوحه هنا في مارب
على المراه سواء من تعذيب سواء من سجن
سواء من همم انتهاكات همم لحقوقها من والى
ليست فقط حقوق حقوق المراه فقط ولكن
حقوقها بشكل عام فهي حقوقها بشكل كبير جدا
الجرائم ولا تسقط وذاكرته اليمنيين ليست
بثوبه يقولوا حقوقيون لتمثل الصور دليل
ادانه لمحاكمه مرتكبها هذا المعرض يحمل
رسالتين رساله للداخل همم الشعب اليمنيه
الذي يتبعها تحت في مناطق سيط الحوثي
وتذكرهم بجرائم وانتهاكات الحوثي واحياء
الذهي الذهنيه للشعب اليمني بما يرتكبوه
مواصله المقاومه الشعبيه والرفض الشعبي
لهذه المليجيات والرساله الاخرى هي
للمجتمع الدولي ومهندسيه تسويات
والمشاورات بان هناك جرائم مرتكبت بحق
الشعب اليمني ولا يمكن القفز على حقوق
الضحايا اكثر من 51 الفجر وانتهاك وثقتها
تقارير حقوقيه ارتكبتها الميليشيات بحق
المدنيين في العاصمه صنعاء خلال العام
الماضي
انتهاكاتو الميليشيه الحوثيه في العاصمه
صنعاء على هذه الجداريه تبقى شاهده على
حجم المعانات الانسانيه في مناطق سيطره
الانقلاب محمود الحميدي لقناه العربيه
مارب
اكد محامي نائب رئيس امريكا السابق العثور
على وثائق السريه في منزل
الاسبوع الماضي وتم احالتها الى مكتب
التحقيقات الاتحادي العثور على وثائقه
مصنفه سريه في منازل الرؤساء الامريكيين
ونوابهم يدل على ان المشكله تكون في ترقيم
هذه الوثائق والتاكد بمن يحتفظ بها وكيفيه
استرجاعها تقرير في الغانم من واشنطن
تبدو قضيه الوثائق السريه التي احتفظ بها
الرئيس الحالي
والرئيس السابق دونالد ترامب مؤشرا على
مشكله حقيقيه تواجهها اجهزه الدوله
الامريكيه مع الرؤساء الامريكي
كيف يتم التعامل مع الوثائق المصنفه
السريه
لكن المساله مختلفه مع الرئيس الامريكي من
الممكن ان نرى الرئيس سبايدر وهو يغادر
وبيده اوراق ويذهب الى مقر الاقامه في
المبنى الرئيسي من البيت الابيض او الى
الطائره لا احد يتابع مع الرئيس الامريكي
ما حصل للاوراق المصنفه سريه
ومرقمه ولا احد يسال عنها او يطلب
استعادتها من الرئيس عندما يغادر او عندما
ينتهي من استعمالها هذه واحده من المشاكل
لكن ما حصل مع بيضه ومن قبله ترامب يتراوح
بين الاهمال والاصرار على عدم احترام
الاجراءات الامنيه وحمايه الوثائق السريه
فبعض الوثائق موجود بحوزه بايضا منذ كان
عضو مجلس الشيوخ الامريكي وقبل ان يصبح
نائبا للرئيس العام 2009
نظام المكتبات العامه وعندما يعطى الرئيس
وثيقه وهي عاده تاتي من السي اي اي او
وزاره الدفاع يجب ان تكون مسجله ومرقمه
الحل الاخر المطروح هو تحويل كل الوثائق
السريه الى النظام الالكتروني وبالتالي
يقفل الدخول اليها بمجرد انتهاء الرئيس من
استعمالها وهذا ما حصل في الاجاز الامني
للرئيس في المكتب البيضاء
بريطانيا لا تزال قضيه الاطفال اللاجئين
المفقودين من الفنادق تتفاعل يتقدم
الثلاثاء وزير الهجره روبرت جنريك حاطه
عاجله لمجلس النواب من شانهم واكد خلال
الاحاطه وجود 200 طفل في عداد المفقودين
13 منهم دون سن 16 وحاله واحده فقط لفتى
وفق تعبيره
فضيحه الاطفال اللاجئين المفقودين من
فنادق بريطانيا هزت الراي العام وارغمت
وزير الهجره على تقديم احاطه
للكشف عن عدد المختفين والاجراءات المتبعه
لتعقبهم
ان اي حاله اختفاء تفاعل بروتوكول الاشخاص
المفقودين الذي يشمل وكاله متعدده بما
فيها الشرطه والسلطات المحليه لتحديد مكان
وجودهم والتاكد من سلامتهم
88% من الاطفال اللاجئين المفقودين غير
مصحوبين بذوبهم من البانيا والبقيه من
افغانستان ومصر والهند فيتنام وباكستان
وتركيا
6400 طفل غير مصحوبين بدويهم في الفنادق
حاله مفقوده ولا يزال مائه طفل في عداد
المفقودين 13 منهم دون سن السادسه 10
وحاله واحده فقط لفتاه
حزب العمال المعارض من جهته هاجم الحكومه
متهمه اياها بالفشل في منع العصابات
الاجراميه من استهداف هذه الفنادق ودور
الاطفال رغم تحذيرات الشرطه وزاره
الداخليه تريد انهاء استخدام الفنادق في
اقرب وقت ممكن خصوصا بعد مطالبه السلطات
المحليه بتامين الرعايه الكامله للاطفال
اللاجئين في بيوت وضمان حمايتهم فيما تعمل
الوزاره على اصلاحات اوسعه لنظام اللجوء
ليكون عادلا وفعلا من اجل صالح العام كما
تقول مصطفى زاروه العربيه لندن
تواجه شركه تويتر دعوه قضائيه من قبل شركه
كراون العقاريه التابعه الى عائله الملكيه
البريطانيه بسبب تخلف فيها عن دفع الايجار
المستحق عن مقر عملها السابق وسط منطقه
اكادير في لندن تاتي الدعوه بعد فصل
مالكها الى الماس اكثر من نصف القوه
العامله للشركه في محاوله لخفض التكاليف
ما دفع تويتر ايضا الى ترك المبنى العام
الماضي من هذه الملكه
شركه تويتر
العقاريه التابعه للعائله الملكيه
البريطانيه بسبب تخلفها عن دفع الايجار
المستحق لمقر عملها الصادق في هذا المبنى
هنا في بيكاديمي في وسط لندن هذه الدعوه
القضائيه ليست الاولى من نوعها يعني طبعا
شركه تويتر
في الولايات المتحده حول المشكله ذاتها
وهي دافع ايجار مكاتب تويتر طبعا هذه
الدعوه تاتي بعد انفصل الماسك نصف القوه
عامله لي الشركه بهدف خفض التكاليف وهو ما
دفع الشركه بالفعل الى همم يعني ترك هذا
المقر همم فهذا المبنى هو واحد من بين
المئات من المباني التي تملكها شركه كراون
العقاريه وهي اكبر ملاك للاراضي هنا في
بريطانيا تولد ارباحا للخزينه البريطانيه
يعود حوالي 15% منها الى العائله الملكيه
البريطانيه من لندن عروب عبد الحق العربي
العربيه
كرئيسه الوزراء وذلك وسط تصفيق وعناق من
منتظرين لتوديعها امام مقر البرلمان
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
قمر السلطات في كوريا الشماليه بفضل اغلاق
كامل لمده خمسه ايام في العاصمه
بمرض التنفسي لم تحدثه حسب ما ذكر ان كان
يوزع ومقره السلط ولم يشيل الموقع الذي
يرصده اخبار كوريا الشماليه الى فيروس
كورونا لكنه اوضح ان السكان في المدينه
الكوريه الشماليه عليهم البقاء في منازلهم
ويجب ان يخضعوا لقياس درجه الحراره عده
مرات في اليوم
اقرب الى نهايه العالم من اي وقت مضى ساعه
القيامه تحركت اذ لم تكن البشريه اقرب الى
نهايه العالم مثل اليوم وذلك بحسب اعلان
من مجموعه العلماء التي تدير ساعه القيامه
في واشنطن ومنذ منتصف الليل 2021 كانت
ساعه القيامه تشير الى ان 100 ثانيه
تفصلنا عن نهايه العالم قبل ان يبدل
المشرفون عليها امس الثلاثاء الى تغيير
العد التنازلي لنهايه العالم وذلك لاول
مره منذ بدا الحرب في اوكرانيا ما اثار
مخاوف من كارثه نوويه اثبات توقيت الساعه
منتصف الليل الا 90 ثانيه وهي المده اقل
منذ بدا العمل بالمشروع الرمزي بعد نهايه
الحرب العالميه الثانيه
بالاساس مشاهدينا تشكل الساعه التي اسسها
العالم البرت اينشتاين وباحثون من جامعه
شيكاغو عام
1947 وتحضينها جامعه شيكاغو الامريكيه
تشكل مقياسا لمدى اقتراب البشريه من تدمير
ذاتها حيث كل ما اقتربه الساعه من بلوغ
منتصف الليل زادت فرصه اندفاع البشر
الى العناوين المشاهدين
امريكا والمانيا تتجهان لتزويد اوكرانيا
بالدبابات وسويسرا توافقوا على تصدير
الاسلحه لكيف
تدريبات الاسرائيليه امريكيه تنطلق اليوم
تحاكي ضربات الهجوميه تستهدف مواقع نوويه
ايرانيه
وسط استعدادات امنيه تظاهره عراقيه قرب
البنك المركزي احتجاجا على ارتفاع سعر
الدولار
وزير الامن القومي الاسرائيلي يتعهد
باستمرار زيارته للمسجد الاقصى رغم الغضب
الفلسطيني
بعافيه
[موسيقى]
باي باي تيكتاتور